we start lacing it with bits of the
truth then we're preparing everybody
preparing everybody for what what is
going on here where is Hollywood really
getting their messages from find out on
this episode of LED live
[Music]
thank you for joining another LED live
we're gonna talk about some amazing
stuff today but before we get into it I
want to thank our patreons because they
help us do these things and bring out
the light that is found in the word of
God showing you what's going on in
society that's dangerous now also we
want to ask that you uh take a look at
our t-shirt website what is our t-shirt
website lightwear dot shop
lightword.shop go there if you find
something interesting go ahead and buy
it it helps us out and you get something
too today we're talking about agents in
Hollywood now this is it looks like
something we've covered in the past here
but what we found was something
remarkable that came out from Australia
Australia so Australia has like three
different news organizations and one of
them the top one came out with a
documentary that talks about exactly how
Hollywood is receiving its information
but before we get on so wait a minute
you mean I mean I thought everybody in
Hollywood had agents yeah everyone does
but these are spiritual agents as we're
going to find out here pretty soon this
is uh and it doesn't really hash that
out until about halfway through but
you're gonna you're gonna see this this
is this is just remarkable that the
characteristics are going to happen here
now the Bible says that we need to guard
ourselves against these deceptions check
this out
Matthew 24 3-4 says now as he sat on the
Mount of Olives the disciples came to
him privately saying tell us when these
will these things when will these things
be and what will be the sign of your
coming end of the end of the age and
Jesus answered and said to them take
heed that no one deceives you it's
interesting to me that the first words
out of Christ's mouth is don't be
deceived as if he knew that the way the
the the deceiver as Satan is called uh
plans his his uh Reckless plan is that
he uses deception
and because that's how we did it in the
Garden of Eden too right you know Jesus
not just answering the question directly
is very kind of interesting like they're
asking like what's going to be this sign
well he's actually letting you know that
one of the signs is the deception when
you see the deceptions yeah that's also
a sign but I think it's it is pretty
interesting that that's that's what he
remarks rather than going oh it'll be
this and this and this when you see
these things then then this will happen
and First Timothy 4 1 says now the Holy
Spirit tells us clearly that in the last
times some will turn away from the true
Faith they will follow deceptive spirits
and teachings that come from demons
I think that's fascinating because
it's almost as if these spirits and
demons will be in a physical form now I
I say that for a reason because what
we're going to find out next is truly
truly fascinating so you ready for this
this is a documentary that was put
together by seven news Australia and uh
they they are hashing out some things
that have been coming out into the U.S
market of things and they're they're
putting pieces together but they don't
have all the truth because they don't
have the biblical Foundation but so they
they think that our government is doing
something
behind the scenes now this isn't a
conspiracy I I say those things you
think oh it's going into conspiracies
now well wait a second remember this is
mainstream media Australia from
well-known uh um documentary makers uh
news anchors and uh interviewing a
well-known Hollywood producer you ever
remember Lois and Clark The New
Adventures of Superman oh yeah this is
the guy and these two guys that they're
going to be interviewing are the guys
that made that show oh interesting so uh
along with a number of others so check
this out this this is the three major
news organizations in Sydney Australia
they have News 9 News 7 and news 10. you
can see the uh this is the the total um
Network shares that each one of these
things have and uh total people
percentage-wise is split pretty much
into thirds but news seven is the top
one you'll see when I play the clips
from this documentary bottom right
corner will be new seven so this is a
legitimate documentary from their
mainstream media I think that's
fascinating so Bryce there is a story
that you have been personally involved
in that I find absolutely fascinating
and it goes to the whole whole mythology
that over the years the U.S defense and
intelligence Community has tried to
influence what Hollywood puts out now
just to explain to our audience you are
a very accomplished Hollywood producer
and screenwriter in your own right
you're actually the former chairman of
the Emmy Awards you've written multiple
award-winning movies
what happened to you and your colleague
Brent Friedman when you were doing the
launch party for your Dark Skies series
just give us a bit of an introduction
we're going to run a a bit of an
interview from Brent Friedman your
colleague but just tell our audience
what the context was for what brings
about to tell us so this this is really
interesting we're going to find out who
this guy is the guy on the right last
and he's in Los Angeles other guys in
Sydney he's the news anchor on the left
here and and uh the guy the producer is
in Hollywood right now but he's had an
experience that that that uh the guy on
the right wants to or getting the left
wants to talk about so let's look into
who is Bryce zabel he is the guy in Los
Angeles right now and it says that I
looked him up on IMDb and this is what
it says about him he's he was a CNN
correspondent turned screenwriter and
has been the Creator and showrunner for
the prime time series written produce
films run the TV Academy created in BC's
Emmy winning main titles science fiction
series Dark Skies
foxes African-American superhero show
mantis uh this this syndicated comic
film adaptation the crow Stairway to
Heaven see TV's Newsroom drama Eng I
mean just you can just read through all
this thing La law you might recognize uh
life goes on Lois and Clark The New
Adventures of Superman just on and on
and on Mortal Kombat yeah I mean
Unsolved Mysteries that's pretty good
yeah I mean this guy is he's legit he's
not just some low-end guy that's that's
not well known in Hollywood this is this
is something major and we're gonna find
out what he says about this story that
he had in just a second here well here's
the interesting thing you talked about
the mythology of the government uh and
and some kind of symbiotic relationship
with Hollywood I don't know how it's
extensive it's been although there are
cases that go back to the at frankly
1950 but I personally have experienced
it with my Dark Skies television series
co-creator Brent Friedman we created a
series called Dark Skies that aired on
NBC in the 90s at the same time the
X-Files was out I I should tell you and
we had an incident that happened to us
that I just have never heard anyone else
have anything quite like it this is what
happened we decided to have a Dark Skies
premiere party for when the show was
first going to air it was a two-hour
episode it was on September 21st 1996
and we had a party 200 people who were
cast and crew and the the network
Executives the studio Executives and we
had it at my house so there's that so we
have all these people coming to my house
to watch the show that has not yet aired
all right and while that was happening
we were approached by a gentleman who
got into our my house a guy that got
into my house I knew everybody else 200
people there knew them all didn't know
this guy and he approached Brent and
myself as the co-creators of the show
said he was from The Office of Naval
intelligence and they wanted to help us
I'm going to let Brent tell a little bit
more of the story now
so I'm going to pause it right there for
a second because I think this is
interesting a good setup he knew
everyone on the set he was the producer
he had a big house apparently I've had
bonfires in my 10 acres in California
where we had 50 60 people over and it
was a lot of people I couldn't fit them
all into my little Warehouse there I had
a little metal building we had on the
property so if he had 200 people over
this guy's got a 6 000 square foot house
or something humongous right so he's
telling people that you know I know all
these people but this guy came in and uh
he said he was from the military we're
going to learn in a second I think by
the characteristics of who this is that
they're not from the military I wanted
to tell you before we get into that more
about Brent because we're going to talk
about what Brent says he's going to go
into uh his friend who was his
co-producer or or closely related while
he was on set Brent Friedman this is
from his uh IMDb he said he was born in
1962 he was a produce and writer of Dark
Skies Mortal Kombat and Star Trek
Enterprise prize so now they're pretty
high up there a well-known well-known
guy he was not a man in Black he
you know he looked like a young
Republican he looked like a young
politician right if anything and he came
up and introduced himself and uh said
that he was a big fan of the show and he
loved what he had seen
and
again the show is in the middle of a
broadcast right for the first time on
television and he's already talking
about that he's seen the whole thing
which struck me as odd
um and as we started to have a
conversation
um he had said yeah I just I was sent
here by some very interested people to
let you know that um we really
appreciate what you and Bryce are doing
with the show and we wanted to help
and that was my reaction my very face
you made was my face and um again I I
can't tell you how surreal this was
because I I'm trying to like keep an eye
on the party but I'm talking to this guy
and I'm
I'm very confused as to who he is and
why I'm having this conversation with
him but it's kind of fascinating so I
keep talking and I say well I don't I
don't understand how do you think you
can help and he said well
you've actually got a lot of truth in
your show but you can have a lot more if
you work with myself and my partners
um we're prepared to come in and tell
you some really interesting things
that's a crazy thing I think it's
interesting how he approached this to
begin with coming up to somebody and
saying you have a lot of truth but there
could be more truth is more like you
have a lot of things wrong or there's
something so let me help you correct or
add more detail or whatever like that
yeah it's interesting we're gonna get
into that a little further because and
I'm going to spoil it here but the the
figure
that you'll find out his name is is
interesting here in a second but the
figure that is um interested primarily
looks and is concerned with how they are
portraying possession
isn't that interesting so we're gonna
get into that little further on but
um
it just gets weirder and weirder and
weirder so here we go did you witness
any of this yeah yeah I did um it's
almost interesting it would have been a
great experiment to put Brent in one
room and me in another room and have us
tell the story because I can confirm all
of the details it was very antagonistic
yeah
um and it the meeting ultimately went
nowhere it's like I think
I I got the sense that this guy that I
met in Bryce's yard who called himself
JC that's all he would tell me about
himself
um that he was trying to broker
something with this military person from
the Navy
um they started throwing around you know
and I don't remember the differentiation
but there was a group called the Aviary
and there was a group group called The
Aquarium they were different
one Aviary was the Air Force I think
right and the aquarium the aquarium was
trying to get the truth out and the
Aviary was trying to shut it down
and so these guys and so I felt that JC
was trying to negotiate something with
the aquarium to get some truths out in
television and they wanted to help us
come up with some story ideas they did
not want story credit and they did not
want money so so they didn't want
anything monetary they didn't want any
credit in the film they don't want
anything monetary but some guy randomly
appears at the uh the The Big Show the
premiere and says you know what I think
I can help you get some truth out and
his name is JC so he's pretending to be
something he's not I think JC is some
interesting
letters letters right right for every
story that you hear like this which is
probably a needle in a haystack right
you've barely heard these kind of things
how often does this really happen
I mean how many times are people showing
up and telling these stories I mean you
you hear like when we played the the
clip um in the anime documentary that
talked about you know the Lion King and
where the original idea of that came
from that was just a rip-off but you
hear everybody that's like you know in
charge of Disney like oh no this
original idea and this and that right
how many of these ideas are actually
brought by weird situations like this
like this is fascinating to me yeah yeah
and it's and what's really interesting
is this guy's in physical form
Satan can manifest himself in physical
form I don't know if this was actually
Satan but I'm convinced it was a minion
of his it was a demonic entity that came
and said hey look this we want to help
you out and I'm going to explain that
more it's going to get even more
detailed as we go further on into it but
um this this is what's this is what's
happening and it reminds me of that
story I think Chris Lang told him one of
his doc documentaries about
um
the man I forget his name he went to
become he wanted to do what he wanted
and serve himself and he went and played
pool at this place and a guy appeared
out of nowhere and said who do you serve
and he said I served myself he said so
be it Serve Yourself and he said from
then on his life changed
um and so I I'll find that clip I'll put
in the show notes but it's it's really
interesting what's going on here how how
these things can manifest themselves
physically
uh another thing about interesting about
the aquarium it was in the uh
it's not an era in aquarium that's
Aquarius Aquarius oh yeah yeah different
than an aquarium what do you think about
that I don't understand exactly if
that's if that's a uh entities that
they're calling their Navy in Australia
or if that's uh something that
he was brokeraging from what he called
the Aquarius and the era or whatever
it's called I forget what his name was
yeah and you know I think they're going
to sell it in whatever their their
masters of deception right right so you
know they're gonna they're gonna pose
this as like you know we've got the
truth and we're trying to get it out and
there's these people that are going to
try to stop us it's like I think
listening to you know how the whole
Marvel universe is really painting this
picture of God is evil and you know we
need to fight against him I think
they're flipping the rules around there
so they're making a story up to try to
push an agenda well I find it really
interesting that if you really wanted to
reach out to the public really I mean
really if you are the Navy or you're
connected to the Navy does it make any
logical sense to you that you would go
through a fictitious Hollywood
television show to try and get the truth
out because you need to get the truth
out does that make sense to you
I mean if if it's classified information
that the Navy's not supposed to tell you
then that guy would get in trouble but
why is he going in covert behind the
door and then coming out in the way of a
false like story
I think I think it's really interesting
because I have had
um
stories uh that have been shown to me
from a guy named Tom Delong and they go
into this a little further down the road
but I don't have that packaged into this
presentation but Tom Delong was
convinced that there was a conspiracy
happening with UFOs and so he went to
the military he got into the Pentagon
and he said you know what I think you
guys need some help revealing this and
they said can you write some fiction for
him can you write some fiction for us
because we do need to present something
we'll help you write this
I think that's interesting though
because if they're asking you to write
fiction doesn't that seem like they're
asking you to write a lie to try to tell
the truth well they they can't they they
this is this is their explanation I
don't know if this is correct or not I
just know that they say that they can't
present this stuff in factual format
because it's classified so if they have
a third party kind of like reverse
engineering right you have a third party
do uh the presentation in fictional
format that party can say it's fictional
I just made this up out of my head so
then it's somebody that works for the
government that disagrees with them
making it classified
so like a leak yeah there's there's
another example of that and it's a
couple of books by Malachi Martin
who was a Catholic priest and worked
very closely with the Vatican and the
Pope and he wrote a book called keys of
his blood and he wrote another book
called Windswept house
and Windswept house is written as a
fictional novel but the idea behind it
is that is based on true events and so
you can't come out and say them publicly
because that would get you in hot water
but if you published a novel and you
changed the names and all that kind of
stuff then it's like telling everybody
without telling everybody which is I
think what Hollywood's really good at
the devil's telling you his plan
but he's using fictitious lies to do it
like I only take it with so much with so
much like level of trust right don't
trust the devil you know it's like if
he's telling you something to me it's
like there's something wrong with that
but that's my point that's my point if
you wanted to tell the truth you would
find some way to really tell the truth I
I just think that using a art form that
really is a master of deception to begin
with smoke and mirrors to try and get
your truth out to me is like proving to
you that it's like but dirty but
it is a way to introduce an idea and I
think what Satan has been doing like
he's been doing for a long time
you know long time and so when you are
trying to make changes in history over
long periods of time you do it a little
at a time you work through generations
you like take this generation you tweak
a little bit you take this generation
you tweak a little bit why would you do
it that way because the memory of the
generation is only so long right and So
eventually that generation forgets or
passes away but you've introduced the
change and it manifests itself in the
next one and so when you're working with
humanity and here he has been alive for
you know so many thousands of years he's
able to manipulate the stream of time
sorry over a long period of time without
necessarily look like he he's tipped his
hand right and so I think it's kind of
the same the same idea with with Fiction
it's like you put it out there and
people get warmed up to the idea right
we see this in Hollywood with all kinds
this stuff you put it out there they get
warmed up to the idea and then when it
happens
it's not so weird right or people are
very accepting of it right yeah no I'm
agreeing with you I I think that it is a
a strange thing that you would use this
medium to try and reveal some kind of
truth to me that tells me like you're a
liar yeah like if you just really wanted
to know something it's it's like a lot
of people that want to know something
it's like with the public press so
they're they're newspapers all over the
world and you know they actually have
secure encrypted ways of submitting
information to them so that it protects
the identity of the individual as a
whistleblower and then they can give the
information out of the press and they're
supposed to be like let the people know
right
but if you're going in a different way
like if I wanted somebody to know
something it seems like that's what you
do you know like go to the press and be
like hey everybody needs to know this
like get it out there
but like going to a novelist or a
Hollywood producer seems like a really
strange way of strange trying to release
revealing they're going to reveal why
they're doing this uh in this next clip
in particular though I remember one
thing that irritated them
um
but
we had a great I guess storyline and
series laid out about a conspiracy right
but one of the things that Brent brought
to the party uh because he had kind of a
horror film background at that point is
we added this thing where the aliens
were we called it the ganglion and they
would infest a person you know
physically and so you had ganglions
coming out of people's mouths and all
that I remember they were like that's
not the way it works yeah okay and and
we were like we don't care if that's the
way it works it's the way it works in
Dark Skies yeah it's a TV show but they
were like no see you're setting
everything back because that's not how
they really do it so they wanted you to
publish what they were saying was the
truth yes yes
yeah see that to me that's weird yeah
exactly that's in a red flag to me
yeah yeah that is very strange that they
want to deal with the topical possession
like that and that they would get
annoyed by that why would the government
get annoyed by how possession Works
in a fake movie okay if this was if this
was a true leak or this was a news
channel okay I could understand the Navy
showing up and being like no no no
that's not really how it works but
you're talking about a fake movie where
these guys could care less how it
actually actually would realistically
happen in the real world you know what I
mean like yeah that's pretty telling
right there wow so check this out I
think we're going to drop into the drip
here in a second drop into the job it's
been like where's your credentials right
you know anybody can say that works
okay let's let's assume that's true for
a moment why would any government agency
that's presumably presiding over an
intentional cover-up come to a TV
program and try and sew it with aspects
of the truth I because JC said to me
that this is It's a drip system right
like get the truth out there in small
ways and you have a television show that
millions of people are watching right
now some people will take it seriously
and if we start lacing it with bits of
the truth then we're preparing everybody
preparing everybody for what what is
going on here I mean this is exactly
what we talk about yeah and they're
saying exactly what what's going on they
said we're preparing everyone through a
gypsum exactly what Keith was saying a
little bit here and there and then It
prepares the Next Generation
yeah for what yeah I I think that these
are also good examples to show you that
that that this is a program it's
designed to program people and like you
said there's millions of people some
people will take it seriously I don't
think everybody walks out of the movie
and is like wow I really believe in this
stuff you know what I mean but some
people actually will or it goes into the
subconscious and and you know 90 of what
we do all day long is from our
subconscious right and so I I think this
is very telling I mean how many times
have you quoted a movie and you'd be
like oh yeah that happened oh by the way
where'd that come from right well that
was set in your subconscious by the last
movie you saw so I can't tell you how
many times when I was in sixth grade
what's interesting is when I was in
sixth grade in 1996 when this TV show
was airing uh we uh kids would come into
our classroom and they would be like uh
quote quote from Saturday Night Live Now
I hadn't seen Saturday Night Live my
parents would let me watch it I don't
know if it came on too late or they just
just like let's not let them watch that
or whatever but I I can't remember just
laughing to myself going what are they
talking about I have no idea but the
rest of the kids in the classroom were
laughing about some quote or something
that happened on on the TV and they
would look at me and they would laugh
and laugh and laugh not at me but just
because they thought it was so funny
and some of it was kind of vulgar so I
was I was I was at a loss but it shows
you that not only do us as adults become
influenced by this but our kids do
drastically that's right so it's
something to be aware of that this is
seeding subtly seeding the mines
and the spiritual realm was coming to
these guys saying you have some truth
and we want to help you push our agenda
yeah there would be no reason logically
for these guys to make this story up
really there would not be you know what
I mean and especially this level of
detail as well so you know the fact that
something like this did happen you know
raises should raise a lot of question
marks in your mind so what is dark skies
because this is the video that they were
making so I looked it up on IMDb Dark
Skies is uh in set in the 1960s America
as a young couple struggles to expose
the truth about a hidden alien invasion
while a secret government organization
follows its own agenda in dealing with
the threat so it's it's your typical
alien you know uh conspiracy uh
documentary or TV series fiction TV
series right yes but do you find this
kind of very interesting that that's
exactly what's going on in real life
I mean they're trying to expose some
alien stuff and then there's some
government agent that's following their
every move I think that's kind of
interesting and he says you have a lot
of Truth in this and we can help you
expose it why is the devil so interested
in an alien fictional video right let's
let's find out
you remember Roger Morneau
Roger mourno is a um a he was an
occultist turned Christian when his
co-workers brought him to Christ let's
see what he says about the future as uh
his priest his satanic priest told him
about what's going to happen with this
agenda I think this is fascinating
and he said it's going to be done in a
unique manner
this Grand plans is going to take people
people are going to eat the stuff
because he says Spirits demonstrated
will he declared himself to be
inhabitants of far distant planets in
the galaxies that are coming to warn the
inhabitants of planet Earth of the
impending destruction of the planet
unless something
seriously
properties done to avoid it so I think
what's interesting is all these things
especially this clip right here is the
military showing actual uh evidence that
they have with their military craft of
things that are appearing on their
Radars on visually to their pilots every
day
there's a pilot that says this is
happening daily and they're not sure why
they want to get it out of their no-fly
zones they want to get it out of their
um their their their systems they sh
they've tried to get get out get rid of
it and they can't get rid of it and they
said it flies faster than our Jets it's
whatever it is they said it is a major
nuisance to us
and what's interesting is these things
aren't like little crafts they're giant
glowing orbs or they appear as Tic Tac
or metal round balls right so when did
this Roger mono video come out so okay
so this video that we just this clip
that we saw was was back in the what is
it the 90s the early 90s yeah it was it
was a while back that he recorded this
but when he actually had this experience
was back in the the 60s it was back it
was a long time ago interesting and so
this this happened with his uh satanic
priest or whatnot he had him tell him
what was the plan for the future
according to the spirits because the
satanic priest openly said he's oh
they're worshiping Lucifer and that all
these all these demons are are um are
are presenting themselves to them so
they can be uh
uh worshiped in front on the altar wow
and so so they said this is how it's
going to happen it's going to be very
strange how this is all going to all
this manifestations and right now we are
seeing this exact exact thing happen
yeah you know you mentioned that also
the shape of these these things
um I've I've heard them described as
clear balls with like this Square Cube
cubed like metallic Cube or something
like that in the middle of this thing
um also you talked about the pill shaped
one um where it was like you know a long
cylinder I think I think they're large
right yeah they're not small items yeah
they're huge they're very large and and
I saw a video one time that was talking
about how how it was flying the pattern
that was flying and it would fly at like
1600 miles an hour I think in an S
format just just racing through Earth
nobody could be inside of this thing I
mean you would just blot against the
wall you know so whatever this is is is
either spiritual or there's something
absolutely crazy going on you can handle
about six to eight g-forces I mean you
go on on YouTube and watch these Pilots
as they're going through this and
they're like
I mean there's stress passing out
passing out yeah and that's what they
train them to do so that if you do go
through these g-forces that you're not
going to pass out while you just these
things are going like 80 times so
g-forces going around in circles and
they are definitely
not human yeah right so I think what's
interesting is the devil's very
interested in this this demonic alien
agenda and I think it's been devised or
Divine
um I think it's been created
intrinsically designed so that it's
difficult to talk about it without
having some stigma on it right and so
let's go back to the documentary to see
what these guys are actually saying
about it as they are Hollywood producers
and uh because they're they're trying to
figure it out too they're scratching
their heads not sure what's happening
but we know what's happening second
Thessalonians 2 9-11 says the coming of
the Lawless one is an according it is
according to the working of Satan with
all power signs and lying wonders and
with all unrighteous deception among
those who perish because they did not
receive the love of the truth that they
might be saved and for this reason God
will send them a strong delusion that
they should believe a lie that they all
maybe condemned who did not believe the
truth but had pleasure in
unrighteousness so what this verse is
saying here is that there will be a huge
deception that's coming and not only
just a little deception but it's going
to be a strong delusion that they should
believe a lie and God will allow this to
happen to separate the good and the bad
the righteous and unrighteous and it
will begin the process before Satan
reveals himself
in the final days because that's what he
wants to do he wants to be worshiped
right
I want to interject something on this on
this one thought that you just presented
here though um
God is not going to allow a strong
delusion without giving you the tools to
be able to make it through that delusion
right and that's why it's really
important to know what the Bible says to
know what this state of the Dead is to
know about spiritualism there's a few
things that God has given us ample
amount of information to the point that
we should not have an excuse right we
should not be like hey sorry I didn't
know there's like this alien showed up
and blah blah you know God's given you
plenty of evidence in the Bible what
these things potentially are or actually
are and we should not be deceived the
the rub here and I think you know people
get hung up on this they're like man
God's God's sending them a delusion like
why would God do that
but if you look at the text you I think
the biggest clue is the last couple
words
when it says they did not believe the
truth but had pleasure and
unrighteousness
that person is making a choice
and they their mind and heart is is sold
out to things that are not
um biblical not godly and they're saying
I want that more than I want the things
of God and because their mind is put in
that condition they're not able to see
the truth you know God allows many
things to happen one of those is a
strong delusion but it's like if you if
your mind hasn't been fortified with
scripture of your mind and heart are not
completely with God then it's easy to be
deceived
so but so for us just to be clear they
were they were on board with the Alien
Invasion aspect of it they just were not
on board with us telling it as a Horror
Story yeah they had they had issues with
that and and to answer your your
question which is a really excellent one
it it's as Brent said
they were looking at a disclosure
scenario how how ultimately does this
secret become known to the public and
they said to us that you know pretty
much what Brent said earlier you just
can't the president can't come out and
say by the way here's everything and and
all at once so they wanted to see more
of the truth through fiction and in fact
that which was exactly what our show was
doing we literally told people in our
sales materials when we sold the series
that we had been approached to tell the
story the true story uh under the cover
of fiction
under the cover of fiction so I I think
it's interesting you said while we were
watching this why not why can't why
can't the government they're still
thinking it's the government that's
coming to them and trying to get them to
to do stuff it's not the government it's
a lie it's satanic beings presenting
themselves as Government beings so they
listen to them the government could come
out and tell us all about this stuff but
they still can't figure out what's going
on with this stuff right the fact that
these guys don't know what's going on
when you ask them what is this they
don't know when you look at the guys
that are literally flying around in in
the fighter jets and they're seeing
these things and they're asking them
what is this they're going we don't know
we don't know you hear that over and
over and over again it's really from a
Christian perspective that we go we we
know what this is yeah you know so I I
think even them it's like it's easy to
get deceived if you just don't even have
that Christian like backing up and
looking the big picture there are other
beings that are here they are Fallen
beans the fact that they would be upset
at the way that we portray possession
you know I mean these are all like
letting them know who these beans are we
just read the verse in the Bible says
that with Satan has all power to deceive
and lie and do those signs so my
question is how much power have Satan
yeah well only as much as God will give
him right but I mean he's been around
for thousands of years he's much more uh
capable I mean if he can go and and
maneuver like these stuff his his
physical being is not like our weak
bodies right I mean it it they the
angels are higher than Humanity yeah can
I answer that question though directly
how much power does Satan have as much
power as you let him have uh that's it
literally he's not sticking a gun to
your head and forcing you when we are
deceived it's because we are allowing
that deception into our life if we
actually hungered in thirst like the
verse said after righteousness and after
the truth we would not be deceived
man 100 so he has no power over you if
you're hungry for the truth
let's check out this next clip one of
the things that I will tell you that
happened is that uh when you shoot a
pilot uh in in the U.S for the for
television uh lots of people actually
are part of the process to make the
pilot but they don't all get to see it
all right so this guy when he showed up
at my house the night of the Premier
party said he had seen the pilot and me
kind of being you know uh well a skeptic
like yourself I said oh yeah well what
happens after a loan guard sees the crop
circle
which I thought well that ought to smoke
him out pretty good and the guy said oh
yeah well that's where they go back to
the Majestic 12 headquarters and they
they perform the surgery which is
exactly what happens in the series and
keep in mind
do you think he was saying that some of
what you were putting in your program
was actually true even though you and
Brent had just made this stuff up that's
exactly what he said he said uh that
they had seen our pilot and uh they
obviously had had I mean they had seen
the pilot and that they thought it was
very good and they I guess they thought
there would be the drip drip drip of
disclosure and we were part of telling
the truth under the cover of fiction
which was kind of the the way that we
sold the dark sky Series in the first
place so I I guess what this fellow was
saying is uh we think there are some
things that you could put into your show
that would be even more helpful now to
that I said I'm a Hollywood producer as
you just pointed out I really don't want
guys from o and I giving me ideas
they're not going to be in our TV series
or whatever on I is like the CIA of
Australia apparently I looked it up it
was it was it has something to do with
with that intelligence agency
so just to tell you what he was saying I
don't want oh and I because he still
thinks it's it's it's government that's
talking to him I don't want one eye in
here I I want to just tell my story
right so I I also find it really
interesting that
um
um this guy is coming to him and he's
trying to prove that he is either aware
of the whole thing right what do you
think he's actually really doing
psychologically he's trying to win their
their oh wow this guy must really know
what's going on right well do you think
the demons are around when they're
filming the thing absolutely yeah oh
that can they communicate with each
other and tell each other like oh yeah
this is what happens in the story no
problem there's probably a guy sitting
right off of over here that's telling
him what to say or whatever or maybe he
was the guy that was present when they
were filming it that's how the Demonic
World works but him throwing that
comment out there to him is going to
make him think that's impossible nobody
else has seen that so now he's gonna
believe what he says or trust him but
I'm call I'm calling this like this is
straight demonic yeah yeah I 100 agree
uh one of the things in the Dark Skies
series is there is a ganglion that kind
of infests somebody's head and then it
gets out of their head that's what
bothered them uh Ross they said well
that's not the way it works and I said
well I don't care how it works this is a
TV series you know where it's drama we
make things up and he goes yeah but you
know that one it's just not quite the
way it works you could do better on that
and he was sitting just like what he
said before I he wanted to reiterate
this in the documentary and I thought it
was it was a good thing to reiterate
because he's going back to being
focusing on the uh the possession of
things why would the government want to
do that so I I I'm just floored at this
whole interview and they kind of end it
right there and kind of just stop and
and and wonder uh we don't really want
to know what's going on but eh we've
made the series anyway yeah that's right
I think it's important to discuss this
topic
um I I really do see the value in seeing
the spiritualism that's attached to
something like this I think there's
going to be a lot of people that are
caught off guard because what they're
dealing with is something physical
something that you're going to
physically see you're going to see with
your eyeballs you're going to see on
television you're going to see like
whatever and this is just getting more
and more complicated I don't think we've
even seen the beginning of this thing
um and all of a sudden it's like they
put out enough of this dripped
information people are gonna start to
believe it you watch right yeah and
that's and and in fact I think Mikey and
I are going to go out on the street and
do some do some interviews do some
polling with some of the areas around
we've actually decided we're not only
going to do polling on the bridge random
people in the park like we've done in
the past for other other producers but
we're also going to be doing uh polling
from people coming out of churches in
the city and seeing what people believe
about this possibility of you know
extraterrestrial life out there that's a
good idea when Mikey and I went and did
it originally for the first documentary
that we made
um the the interesting thing that that
came out of that kind of like talking
with people I was actually shocked at
how many people even believed in aliens
or had some sort of alien exposure but
when we asked them at the end of our
talking you know like do you believe in
aliens and pretty much everyone said yes
and we said like you know are you are
you Christian yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes and it was just like wow or they
believed in God or something like this
and so you can see real quick how even
the Christian world is is is going to
get
deceived if they don't have the correct
picture absolutely Hollywood has always
no matter if it's if it's a um a
Hallmark movie or if it's just you're
Disney or if it's the natural Hollywood
or Marvel or whatever you have they've
always always liked playing in
titillating on the idea of hey is this
good but actually it's bad and is this
bad well actually it's good they mix
that in your mind so you're confused and
and then they present that as as a good
movie and so this what you're saying is
absolutely right that's that's what's
happening it's it's messing with
people's minds yeah I want to thank you
for watching this program this is a
fantastic program and we can't do it
without our patreons thank you every
single one of you we can't do it without
you and if you would like to also
contribute please go to patreon.com
littlelife Studios and uh help us as we
continue to go through the Bible and see
exactly what's going on in society
God bless you Blue Light Studios is a
faith-based media Ministry with a
passion for today's youth by God's grace
our videos has been circulating YouTube
and reaching thousands of people I mean
seriously thousands of people as the
popularity of our videos began to rise
we realize a problem what about the
countries that only speak English we
heard your requests and having an answer
by creating new life Studios
International this YouTube channel is
assigned to be a hub for people to enjoy
little life Studios Production and their
own native tongue a big thank you to all
the volunteers who have helped us with
translation voiceovers and editing we
encourage you to utilize this Source by
subscribing and sharing our videos with
your friends and family welcome to the
video Bible study Series where we will
explore a variety of Bible topics using
video and print what is humility do we
need God's law can I understand stand
the Holy Spirit yes you can and we're
going to solve that today in five
minutes or less they're designed to
engage You by watching a five minute
video having a discussion on the topic
and Diving deeper into it with a lesson
study
each study asks questions has discussion
points and or has activities
overall we developed this project for
you to have a closer walk with Jesus as
you explore relevant topics either in a
group setting or on your own we hope you
find these a blessing if you want more
information go to
www.littlelightstudios.tv or find us on
your favorite social media platform
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]